يقولون انهم سلطان بس ما قالوا سلطان شنو
او ايش الحقيقه انه لجسد سليم يجب ان يحصل
للانسان على ساعه نوم كافيه لكن اللي عنده
مشاكل في النوم شو يعمل شو يسوي صعبه
والله مشكله صعبه الحل ولكن على كل حال
الدراسه جديده مشاهدينا وعادل بتقول انه
انقطاع النفس النومي غير المنضبط الذي
يؤدي لتوقف النفس والاستيقاظ المتكرر ربما
يضر بصحه الدماغ مستقبلا يعني اللي بيفيق
بالليل وهو مش قادر يتنفس لازم يخاف على
دماغه عن جد الله يسترك هذه الدراسه التي
اجريت في الولايات المتحده تؤكد ان من
يعانون من هذه المشكله او من يقضون وقتا
اقل في النوم العميق اصيبه بضرر اكبر
بالماده البيضاء في الدماغ وهي عباره عن
الانسجه التي تشكل الروابط بين الخلايا
خلايا الدماغ وبقيه الجهاز العصبي والمزعج
بالامر مشاهدينا انه ما من علاج لمثل هذه
التغيرات في الدماغ وبتاكد الدراسه انه
الانسان بيحتاج الى ايجاد طرق لمنع حدوثها
اصلا او الحد من تفاقمها على كل حاله
تفاصيل حول هذه الدراسه وما كشفت عنه رح
يكون مع لميس ابراهيم ناموا
بحسب دراستني منظمه مايو كلينك البحثيه
الامريكيه حول صعوبات النوم فان 936 مليون
بالغ في العالم اعمالهم بين الثلاثين الى
الستين عاما يعانون من توقف التنفس اثناء
النوم مع العلم ان كل 10% من الوقت الذي
يقضيه الفرد في النوم العميق تسجل زياده
في كثافه المدى البيضاء في الدماغ وهي
بمثابه كابلات تربط كل شيء معا وتوصل
الاشارات بسرعه فائقه بين الخلايا العصبيه
وتبين ان حوالي 34% من المشاركين في
الدراسه مما يعانون من انقطاع النفس
النومي الخفيف 32 منهم يعانون من انقطاع
النفس النومي المعتدل واربعه وثلاثون
يعانون من قطاع التنفس النومي الشديد
الدراسه تؤكد ان 10% من نوم الموجه
البطيئه اي النوم العميق يعادل ثلاث سنوات
من الشيخوخه لدى الانسان
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو اختصاصي في امراض الجهاز
التنفسي والطب والعنايه المركزه او طب
العنايه المركزه دكتور بسام منصور اهلا
وسهلا فيك دكتور معنا صباح الخير يا دكتور
اهلا وسهلا
كويس الحمد لله يعني
دراسه في حوالي مليار شخص بالعالم بعانوا
من السليب ابنيه او انقطاع النفس المتكرر
اثناء النوم وانه لما يكون في يعني نقصان
بعشره في الميه من جوده النوم هذا بخلي
ادمغتنا تكون اكبر من عمرها بسنتين ونصف
تقريبا كل شيء مخيف اكيد هي مش اول دراسه
بتبين لنا خطر اصلي بامني او انقطاع النفس
النومي في دراسات كثيره وهيدا مرض صار
مدروس جدا من الاخر 20 30 سنه وفيني اقول
انه هو مرض العصر الحقيقه
والخطير بهالمرض اكثر انه تشخيصه قليل
يعني من اصل مثلا في احصائيين عملت بسنه
2015 بالولايات المتحده الامريكانيه
الامريكيه بينت انه في حوالي 28 او 29
مليون مصاب مشخص منهم فقط 4 ملايين
اشخاص نفسهم ما بيعرفوا انه بصير المشكله
انه الاعراض هي بتكون اعراض عامه غير
نوعيه مثل التعب مثل النقص النشاط الخمول
النعاس النهاري اليومي ولكن في امراض
ثانيه مترافقه ممكن تلفت نظر الطبيب
المعالج مثل ارتفاع الضغط الشريان المزمن
هاي ممكن تلفت نظر طبيب القلب لطلب فحوصات
بخصوصا المرض هذا
وقد تصل ايضا لنقص الرغبه الجنسيه
الشخير وانقطاع النفس طيب الدكتور يعني
الشخص ربما ينام يقول لك والله انا انام
بحكم العمر ربما انام اربع خمس ساعات
وانتهى الموضوع لكن هي الفارق هي هي نوعيه
النوم الكواليتي نوم عميق او لا كيف يعرف
انهم قاعدين هو الحقيقه يلجا هو الى
الطبيب قسم الاكبر من الناس اللي بتيجي
تعاني من الشخير هو الحقيقه الشريك اللي
بيكون عم يشكي يعني سلبي مش ايجابي يعني
الشريك نفسه عم يشكي انه الزوج او الزوجة
عم تشخر فهذا هيدي الامر هو الاكثر حاله
بتجيب المريض عند الطبيب وبتشكي وبتبلش
الفحوصات والتشخيص هو مرتبط بشكل مباشر
دائما
وليس كل سليب ابني هو شخير ولكن كتير هي
من الرزق فاكتورز اللي بتلفت نظرك او
عوامل الخطوره اللي بتلفت النظر انه ممكن
الانسان يكون عنده هي الشخير كون الرجل مش
انثى لانه هو الاكسب خطوره للاصابه
بهالمرض مثل ما بنعرف كون في امراض مزمنه
التعب النهاري هذه عوامل خطوره طيب دكتور
يعني هل البعض ربما يشرب
زهورات او اشياء اعشاب يحاول انه ياهل
نفسه للنوم ولكن لا فائده او حتى البعض
يذهب الى انه ياكل دسمه ثقيله نعم للاسف
هي هلا يمكن ما في وقت نحكي عن الاليه
المرض هيدا المشكله
بيكون في انسداد نحن عم نحكي عن انقطاع
النفس النومي الانسدادي اللي هو بشكل اكثر
من 80% من انقطاع النفس عم نحكي في انسداد
بمجرى الهوائي العلوي هيدا اللي بقدي
للشخير وبنفس الوقت بيؤدي لنقص الاكسجين
اثناء النوم هون الخطوره انه الاكسجين ما
بيوصل بشكل كافي لانسجه الجسم مبيناتها
الدماغ اللي هو العضو الذبيل الاهم بالجسم
وهذا له اثر على
المدى الطويل
من ضعف في النشاط من خمول من نقص بفعاليات
الجسم كلها بما فيها يعني انتهى وقتنا بس
وديت اسالك بشكل يعني سريع عن العلاج
علاجه يكمن في علاج اصل المشكله شو اللي
بسبب انقطاع النفس للاسف هو عاده البدانه
طبعا وعامل خطوره ممكن نعالج البدانه ممكن
نعكس البدانه ولكن العلاج عاده بيكون
باستخدام جهاز الضغط الايجابي اللي بنحطه
على الفك فهو مرض مزمن بده علاج مزمن
وطويل الامد هل البعض يلجا الى جهاز
الاكسجين اثناء النوم هل هذا مفيد ولا هذا
العلاج الاساسي بصراحه هذا الاساس شكرا
الدكتور
بسام منصور استشاري او اختصاصي امراض
الجهاز التنفسي وطب العنايه المركزه شكرا
اهلا وسهلا لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات